after days of heavy rain landslides
along with tidal search that has
battered the hill region of Southeast
Bangladesh news started to emerge of the
extent of damage as Walters slowly
started to recede in the area sajida
begum and her family barely managed to
get away when the flash flood hit their
home like many others she and her
husband are now trying to rebuild their
home
the water was almost neck High we didn't
have the time to salvage most of the
goods whatever items were they got
damaged
a widow with two children escaped the
landslide
during Heavy Rain a tree fell on my home
damaging it completely somehow we
managed to get away and eventually got
rescued and took shelter here
many are still in desperate need of food
drinking water and Arjun medical
assistance this is one of the many
shelters set up by the government for
vulnerable people
Southeastern Hill tracks region of
Bangladesh
thousands of homes and livelihoods were
destroyed in the regions and in Cox's
Bazaar where nearly a million rohingya
refugees are sheltered was not spared by
the bad weather at least four people
died there authorities said they're
trying to reach all places
there are members of the Bangladesh
police and Border guards and we were all
working together to help in this crisis
communication was disrupted in some
places many places were also left
without an electricity mobile networks
or running water members of the armed
forces are now assisting local
authorities
as part of the post-flood scenario our
Medical Teams are working in different
zones to help prevent the spread of
water-borne diseases we are also
Distributing hot meals to different
areas
for many it could take months and even
years to recover from the loss while the
Madoff is here predicts improved weather
condition in the coming days many here
are spending their days in fear of more
rains can be Chaudhry Al Jazeera
rangamati Southeast Bangladesh